[Musique]
le monde est passé au stade de la
génération de braises, il y aura quelqu'un
quelque part qui fera ça si ce n'est pas
moi dans quelqu'un d'autre
[Musique]
il y a déjà beaucoup de scientifiques qui
se lèvent et ils expriment déjà
leurs objections à cette recherche qui est
la bonne chose et puis c'est que
le public devrait être plus conscient et
vraiment se soucier de la recherche liée
aux êtres humains. Je pense que l'édition génétique
peut avoir des conséquences inattendues, donc c'est un
terrain inexploré et cela doit être
pris au sérieux,
vous le savez.  La question de l'édition génétique est
sérieuse car elle comporte des problèmes éthiques, sociaux
et de sécurité et elle ne peut pas être
réalisée sans
des lignes directrices claires qui couvrent toutes les questions éthiques,
sociales et de sécurité. Cependant, c'est un
moment de l'histoire car c'est la
première de ces deux questions.  les bébés semblent
être les premiers bébés à éditer le génome, c'est donc
un point capital pour l'industrie
[Musique]
pour ce cas spécifique, je pense que c'est un, je
suis fier, en fait, je ressens des produits si
c'est un, mon bébé peut avoir la même
situation, je vais l'essayer en premier
[Musique]
toi